the movie opens with a terrifying scene
of a woman drenched in blood she is
swinging herself with the help of a
chain while sobbing moments later she
pulls herself up and commits the
unthinkable as she breathes her last
estranged device falls out of her hand
the movie then shifts to a woman named
Ella Patel who is seen attending her
friend Sean's baby shower however she
seems to be unable to find her place
within the circle of France as everyone
is talking about pregnancy and babies
gross Ella is a local celebrity
architect who has been happily married
to Aiden Patel for 10 years despite
being in her late 30s Ella does not want
to have any children as she does not
want to go through the tough stages of
pregnancy while at the party her friends
ask her when she is going to have
children to which Ella says that she is
very happy with her current life hearing
this her friends wonder how one can be
happy without children at home Aiden
wants to raise their family as well but
despite this he is supportive of Ella's
decision because he does not want to
force her like everyone else does one
day on the urging of her husband Ella
visits a doctor named Dr Weber to get
tested for breast cancer this is because
her mother died at the same age because
of it it is supposed to be just a
regular checkup but the doctor seems a
little too concerned about Ella's
decision to not conceive she suggests
that Ella's biological clock is unlike
most women and that with the right
medication and treatment her opinion
about childbirth might change the doctor
then talks about a clinic which is
testing out a new hormone drug intended
to fix the biological clock of women she
asks if Ella wants to give it a try but
the latter declines citing her busy
schedule nevertheless Dr Weber provides
her with her contact information asking
Ella to reach out if she has a change of
heart later that evening Aiden and Ella
are visited by her Father Joseph for
dinner while dining Joseph brings up the
subject of pregnancy everyone in this
world is obsessed with pregnancy much to
Ella's already mounting frustration
indirectly he expresses his desire for a
grandchild to carry on their lineage he
further pressures her pointing out that
she's a Jewish descendant of Holocaust
Survivors apart from her friends and
Father's pressure Ella's social media is
also up with pregnancy related content
and pictures of babies all these factors
lead Ella to feel that she is letting
everyone down and fears that there is
something wrong with her at midnight
while engrossed in her office project
Ella recalls her doctor's suggestion of
an experimental clinical approach that
can fix her hormonal imbalance after
contemplating it for a while she decides
to give it a try though she refrains
from informing her husband due to the
uncertainty about its potential success
the next day Ella departs from home
feigning the need to carry out some
office work for a few days however once
she drives away she contacts her boss
and explains her inability to continue
with the ongoing project even though it
was her dream job following this she
drives to the referred clinic and checks
in where she notices the infinity symbol
placed in different spots around the
facility a short while later she is
approached by Dr Simmons who gives her a
brief Lowdown about the experimental
drug that they have created to assist
the women like Ella Ella's first session
begins the very following day during
which Dr Simmons learns about her
tokophobia an intense fear of bong wraps
I mean pregnancy she then tries at a
sort of Rorschach test on Ella where she
places a few cards in front of her and
asks her what she sees Alice sees three
things a figure of a tall woman a pile
of bugs and a grandfather clock soon the
doctor sets up a treatment plan for her
and also provides her with some medicine
in the next therapy session Ella and the
doctor discussed the symbolism behind
the three things that she saw earlier
Ella explains that the cluster of
spiders or bugs signifies the trauma her
family endured during the Holocaust
where the Jewish people were
exterminated like bugs similarly Ella
interprets the grandfather clock as her
family's only heirloom from before the
Holocaust and she perceives it as her
grandfather's coffin this represents the
pressure she feels to carry on her
family line after closely considering
Ella's insights Dr Simmons theorizes
that both the bug and the grandfather
clock probably stem from Ella's fear
since the Jewish Holocaust which was
basically about well-cultured people
killing each other and now Ella fears
bringing a child into a world is almost
the same the doctor then inquires about
the tall woman but Ella has no idea
about that one that's just a big ass
lady following this session Dr Simmons
proposes that Ella consider implanting a
small device inside of her so that she
can become pregnant she explains that
the device in addition to the pills will
permanently remain inside of her and
release additional hormones required in
order to help with the pregnancy Ella
isn't sure about it and decides to take
some time to think back in her room Ella
begins to experience unsettling
occurrences At first she notices a
spider on her bed but it mysteriously
vanishes as she tries to kill it
indicating that it's a hallucination
secondly the incessant Tick Tock of the
room's clock disturbs her she attempts
to turn it off but the clock continues
to tick unable to Bear it she runs its
side and meets with a fellow patient who
offers her a cigarette while they talk
the woman reveals that it's her final
night at the facility and she is feeling
like being graduated after a brief
conversation the woman says goodbye and
departs as soon as she leaves the area
Ella suddenly notices the tall woman
prompt her to rush back to a room
fearing her surroundings she calls her
husband whose voice helps her to calm
down the following day Ella undergoes
the next stage of treatment it involves
entering a huge tank as part of a
desensitization procedure intended to
address any psychological barriers
related to pregnancy upon getting inside
the tank LS sees some gruesome imagery
of childbirth which deeply unsettles her
and prompts her to scream in agony
urgently she pleads to be released from
the tank shortly after the tank opens
revealing the same tall woman before her
filled with panic Ella attempts to flee
but slips in the process and sustains a
minor injury to her forehead rendering
her unconscious after a while she
regains her Consciousness and finds Dr
Simmons by her side Allah inquires about
the tall woman but the doctor asserts
that the woman was a clinic nurse
despite Dr Simmons providing video
evidence from both inside and outside
the tank Ella remains unconvinced she
expresses a desire to return home but Dr
Simmons insists that Ella's Choice was
voluntary so she must stick to it or
else their work would be in vain on the
final day of the session Ella is
inserted with the device and is asked
not to have intercourse for at least
three weeks
that got to do with the duck having
completed the session Ella drives back
home but the unsettling Visions keep on
haunting her she sees the scary tall
woman on the road which freaks her out
even though that jump scare device has
been overused already at this point
after a while of driving Ella finally
returns home but she doesn't appear to
be the same person as before Aiden
notices this change and inquires about
it but Ella just pretends to be tired
due to the long drive apart from all
this Ella develops an unexpected craving
for eggs and she gulps them down without
any hesitation even more than Gaston as
the days pass by Ellis Health starts to
deteriorate and she often gets
hallucinations the scene then changes to
her birthday and we see Ella and Aiden
host a gathering with friends including
Sean since Ella is a great architect
Sean wants her to install a beautiful
Nursery in her room for her upcoming
baby stop talking about babies unpc says
Ella during the birthday celebration
Ella continuously stares at Sean's
pregnant belly and asks for permission
to touch it when the latter agrees she
places her head against the belly
surprising everyone this impresses
everyone azella is interacting with a
baby for the very first time in her life
but then something very weird happens
Ella hello a large spider on Sean's
belly and as a result she asks her to
stay still Ella then grabs a book and
almost hits her friend's pregnant belly
but she is soon stopped by another
friend and Aiden preventing the
potential harm in the following scene
Ella heads to the hardware store to
purchase paints for her friend's Nursery
installation during her time there she
struggles to distinguish between
different colors indicating that she is
going colorblind just then she receives
a call from Dr Simmons who inquires if
she is having any side effects despite
all the ongoing mental disturbances Ella
falsely claims that everything is all
right after the call she proceeds to
Sean's place to start her work sadly she
is unable to focus as the persistent
hallucinations and distressing tank
video continue to plague her thoughts
later in the evening Ella and Aiden pay
a visit to Ella's father and together
they go through old family pictures at
this very moment they stumble upon a
hidden picture of Ella's grandmother who
happens to be the same tall woman she
keeps having visions of here we learn
that Ellis fear comes from generational
trauma and she doesn't wish to pass it
on Ella it was really disturbed by the
picture as well as the ticking sound of
the grandfather clock decides to leave
upon arriving home she realizes that she
left her pills at Sean's Place despite
the late hour she rushes to retrieve
them this is when Sean discovers that
Ella has ruined her room by painting
horrific figures on it just then her
water breaks and she goes into labor
Ella becomes so fascinated by this that
she sweeps the water from the floor and
smears it on her face
gooey she then tries to force Sean to
give birth right now but this act
ultimately leads her to getting thrown
out of the house after a while Ella
receives a call from her father who says
that he has fallen down she rushes to
his house to help him only to be
triggered by the ticking of the
grandfather clock unable to tolerate it
any longer she grabs some tools and
destroys the clock two weeks have passed
since the therapy session and Ella's
desire to have a baby suddenly
intensifies she confides her wish to
Aiden and the couple decides to have
intercourse right away however as they
proceed the implanted device within Ella
gets in the and inadvertently injures
Aiden oh like Hawk causing bleeding when
Ella rushes to get some gauze from
Aiden's bag she notices the Infinity
logo of the facility on it here we get
to know that Aiden knew about the clinic
the entire time and that he purposefully
nudged Dr Webber to suggest it to his
wife when confronted Hayden admits that
he just wanted her to have a baby by her
choice Furious by the Betrayal Ella
drives to the facility and directly
confronts Dr Simmons she demands the
immediate removal of the implanted
device however the doctor responds that
the device isn't meant to be removed and
that doing so might lead to permanent
infertility hearing this Ella begins to
panic hysterically Simmons attempts to
pacifier but Ellis soon realizes that
the entire procedure is nothing but a
grand delusion just like the visions of
her grandmother she claims that her
process is doing nothing but forcing
women into feeling a certain way a way
in which society wants them to feel but
not allowing them to be who they are
with this realization Ella rips at the
implant on her own as she does so she
regains her normal scene because the
colors which have been absent from her
vision reappear she finally feels that
she has become the same person as she
was not long after the police arrive at
the facility looking for her but she
drives away immediately soon Aiden calls
her and reveals that he was the one who
called the police because of what she
has done at her father's place this is
when Ella retraces the moment that she
was destroying the grandfather clock in
reality because of the influence of the
drugs she actually killed her father
instead of the clock in her defense it's
an easy mistake to make devastated by
this harsh reality Ella pulls over on
the side of a Cliff Road she exits her
vehicle and surrenders herself to the
police the cops hand cover and are about
to escort her away but Alice suddenly
makes a run and jumps off the cliff in a
final tragic act the scene at the start
of the movie also depicts a woman who
had been implanted with the same device
her life was destroyed by the
hallucinations so she ended it all just
like Ella
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching